[Music]
hey welcome back to off the record where
we
talk about whatever we want
we've got special hosts casey special it
sounds like he's good happy birthday
casey happy birthday
happy birthday change the subject quick
happy birthday no not that birthday
subject again i don't like the birthday
subject
too much emphasis it's a day when do you
think you're gonna die oh that's a great
question
i changed the subject what the [ __ ] are
you so ungrateful that's a deep question
though
any [ __ ] moment that's why you gotta
live it up homie
yeah you never feel that way
sometimes i'm like i could drown right
now in this [ __ ] jacuzzi
when you're chilling in the jacuzzi you
could be like i could [ __ ] drown true
right or like right on an airplane and
i'm like if this plane goes down there's
nothing i could do
i have thoughts of death on airplanes
but statistically that's
very you could probably get hit with
lightning before you die from an
airplane
really oh yeah if i get hit by lightning
that'd be pretty cool and if i died that
way
you [ __ ] die you probably you're
statistically like
more probable of dying on a [ __ ]
bicycle ride than in the airplane think
about that for sure
bicycle have you heard about the cat who
got struck by lightning twice
the cat oh another guy he's a he's like
a jazz
dude he's a beat nick going hey cool cat
daddy oh yeah
remember that i'm cool you gotta
remember that
[Laughter]
imagine a much cooler hat on me right
now i know you have four cats but i
didn't know you like cats that much
we need a beret and a cigarette for him
what happened to that guy
did he die the second time no he's just
the guy where i guess in life he goes
around does speaking engagements and
everyone's basically like i'm so glad
i'm not you that's crazy
like i think like benjamin franklin i
don't think he got struck by anything
benjamin button got struck by
i thought he was flying a kite and they
[ __ ] uh
bottled electric key stopped it he
remembered that
i heard that story's not even real from
who come on that's american history
what the [ __ ] you talking about i heard
they just make [ __ ] up like though like
these fables i thought that [ __ ]
happened and then he became a president
did you hear washington across the
delaware because he just walked right
across it because it was so small back
then
yeah he cut down the cherry tree as well
yeah the cherry tree i thought it was
apple juice
he had that really big friend paul
bunyan yeah
the really big but the blue ox the blue
ox yeah and then johnny appleseed that
had a raccoon on his head
next to confucius yeah that was his
secretary of state
johnny appleseed dude that'll be so
tight if we had american avengers
as our like yeah who yeah because you
know like in chinese folklore or like
whatever
you have like the original emperor and
then like the you have like the whole a
team
yeah it's like a mythical monkey yeah
yeah and then the general the red face
all the guys from dynasty warriors
remember the video game dynasty warriors
they were all the it's like the chinese
avengers right yeah
we need that for america avengers we
need we need like george
washington is like captain america yeah
we need like
i don't know captain china captain china
no no for america for america man who
would make the list for uh
for the american avengers george
washington benjamin franklin for sure
abe lincoln abe lincoln george
washington carver
okay i don't know what the [ __ ] he
invented the peanut oh yeah yeah yeah he
invented
invent the peanut peanuts yeah oh it's
like you could invent a peanut well
you just stuff he deserves to be there
he gave it to purpose
yeah yeah right lewis and clark the
explorer sacagawea
yeah yeah oh i like her michael jordan
[ __ ] yeah yep michael jackson michael j
alda michael
michael bolton all the michaels i think
we're
michael michael j fox michael j fox
yeah that's american royalty michael b
jordan's gotta prove himself a little
bit but
he's too new he's not a legend just yet
dude we'll see how he goes
he's doing too many prime videos suck
yeah yeah i don't like the cruise at all
i'm not a big fan i'm not into the crazy
either actually creed one was kind of
cool
i couldn't get into it i couldn't get
into it i wasn't rooting for him
how about that yeah they [ __ ] up i
think they made me roof for him by the
end but by the beginning he's like
yeah i don't know like i'm a rich kid
and like they don't know like i i've
i have never lost a fight and it's like
oh cool i'm not rooting for you at all
and then at the end he had conflict and
i'm like fine i like you now
it's too late i didn't even get to that
part i stopped watching i like sylvester
stallone
me too he was great damn we turned from
american heroes to [ __ ]
they are american heroes they're the
expendables
hey rocky's rocky's on the list bro
rocky's yeah he fought for america
maybe not sylvester stallone but rocky
yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's what i want we gotta go
ancient like
like johnny appleseed that's an american
companions
balbanian yeah paul bannion huckleberry
finn walt disney
uh john smith the dude who like [ __ ]
uh pocahontas yeah
yeah john smith i heard he didn't doggy
with her too
the two-dimensional one
what was that live-action pocahontas
that's messed up man you're taking this
too far
wow bro at this climate you're gonna
pull some [ __ ] like this right not the
climate for that we heard
by the way i heard she had a perfect ass
really i heard it was perfect like the
golden ratio i heard it was
10 out of 10 out of 10. the golden ratio
is actually based off pocahontas wow
you have to remember that not the live
action bro like this guy
you know what i mean you have to
remember though in those days the finest
asses was like
george washington's wife is like yeah
you know it wasn't it wasn't the
greatest situation
what about franklin roosevelt from
france
we're talking about before why is
andrew jackson so like wow like the 20
dollar bill
yeah i mean like come on yeah why does
he get the 20 bill i thought he was 10
bucks
nice 20 20. 20. are they all cancelled
now we're like all of them slavers
i think they're all they're all canceled
bro that's why the fiat currency is
going down huh
that's why everyone's in a bitcoin dude
because satoshi nakamoto never had no
slaves
that's why whoever's watching this that
wasn't into bitcoin that's what's sold
out
they're like you know what whoever's
watching this that was into pocahontas
is hating us right now
that was very true that's your old
mostly bart because you brought the live
they're like well
i want historians to explain that i'm
inaccurate about pocahontas's ass
that's what i want in my perfect world
you tell me you tell me why i'm wrong
they correct me about that
i remember watching a pornos called
pocahotis
hey lisa ann as sarah palin that's going
on the list
yeah that goes on the list sarah palin's
up there no
it's too new too he's talking about old
people naylan palin only nailing paper
no he's talking about like like 1800s
and earlier we need like folklore and
legends
i don't know that many i think we got a
popeye that's our american hero oh the
kfc general
oh yeah miss yeah colonel he should be
one yeah yeah
popeye the colonel the [ __ ] who
started the mcdonald's
ray kroc yeah can't not
[Laughter]
good mr clean see that this is this is
what i'm doing this is america
or the little paper clip on microsoft
word that's the america i know
the hawaiian punch guy kool-aid guy bro
but but that might be a little sensitive
because i know the hawaiians like to
claim him
oh yeah is that even from hawaii i don't
even know
that's why kool-aid that's mainland dude
is it yeah that's amazing
yeah yeah yeah that's a part of hawaiian
folklore that's hawaiian history yeah
and that was before we came
there so that i don't want to claim
history lessons from this hallway
we can't claim it that's
that's the [ __ ] all-american avengers
right there brands
and [ __ ] folklore yeah put that
together mr clean for sure is like he's
he's the head honcho can you imagine
like when people discover our [ __ ] in
the future like hundreds of years from
now
they're gonna say like they believe in
these myths
and it's the [ __ ] hamburger helper
they're gonna see these commercials the
michelin tiger guy
yeah all i know is that in hawaii you
just say punch you don't have to say
yeah they hawaiian party lnl's hawaiian
barbecue barbecue
barbecue they all have a punch thank you
oh man that's a good
dumbest conversation in a while but but
we hope people take it very seriously
though we threw up some good names in
there though
we did we threw some good names in there
i mean we probably could have said
something like real heroes but
honestly let's go back to the death
thing oh wait
can we introduce what about the raising
guys they're raising the raisins
oh yeah those dudes they all did like
the blues they did the whole town stuff
yeah those are some blues legends dude
what about
what about joe camel then oh yeah
or the marlboro man but they all
disappeared because they got lung cancer
and died
yeah no one ever talks about that or
just the stage coach from wells fargo
yeah oh yeah it's horseless right is it
just a stage card i have no [ __ ]
ideas
stage comes with dust behind it yeah
that's such an unfortunate brand
not a good logo i don't think right yeah
it's just a stagecoach at least bank of
america is a guy [ __ ] going like this
in a suit like that's how it feels
across the american flag if you bank
with them
i was like what makes me
want to close my account right now and
spectrum is just a guy who picks up in
the next song
and then just randomly throughout the
day just unplugs your internet cables
yeah yeah
but he's definitely picking up from
india customer service
hello please hold for five hours we
can't hear you
that would be tight if we shot
commercials of the way
it actually is we should like like a
pizza brand you get it
nothing worth fighting for was ever won
without sacrifice
this is a one-time gig when it's done
we're done
a touching reunion
[Music]
my name is yuffie
[Music]
today's video is brought to you by final
fantasy
7 remake integrate for the ps5 baby
i'm pretty excited that's why i got my
cloud hair going on right now
i got my homie barrett here on the side
yes uh and i think
you've even got the voice down too i
just watched the trailer
yeah and that [ __ ] looks crazy the
graphics
are insane like half the time i felt
like i was controlling like real people
moving around
so it's on 4k so if you have a 4k tv
or a screen it's gonna be nuts like
whatever you liked about final fantasy
now the texture is even more improved
when they're running around in the
warehouse it looks real it's insane
it's crispier and get this it's coming
out
june 10th baby that's super super it's
really soon so can't wait
we're only a few weeks away so if you
really want this you can pre-order
yours now go to sq ex dot link slash
remake
otr so get that go to that link to
pre-order because you know it's gonna go
fast anytime it's final fantasy anything
or ps anything
goes really fast so pre-order yours
s-q-e-x dot link slash remake
o-t-r go see the trailer right after
this episode
because it's amazing sick dude
flip the [ __ ] toppings here you go
you open it like why the [ __ ] is the
cheese
on this side and it's like off the pizza
dude legit spectrum
i'm not even kidding it sounds like a
joke they just sent me another modem
and then they charged you florida well
no they no they told me voted
i got a fedex notification that a
package was being sent to my house and i
was like wow i don't know what this is
for i don't buy anything ever
and then uh package shows up it's for
steve green i'm like holy [ __ ] this
never happens always for nikki
then i open it it's a modem and i'm like
and they're like welcome to spectrum i'm
like oh my god these [ __ ] sent me
another modem and they're trying to get
me to sign up again like what the [ __ ]
but is it an updated modem of what you
have right now i assume
so now because i got a text 35 minutes
ago at jk this is two days after i got
the money because i was like i have to
take this back to the ups store this
sucks ass
yeah oh they're gonna charge me well
they said you have to update your modem
or your shit's going offline
but they didn't tell me this formerly in
any way i checked my email i checked my
all my notifications they have my number
anytime
i don't pay this thing on like on time
yeah they
they let me know but i have to do that
now and i didn't even know spectrum's
[ __ ] dude
the amount of mail that they give you to
and i've went paperless
long time ago and they never listened to
that they give me so much [ __ ] mail
every goddamn day just trying to sign up
for internet i already have internet the
phone bill
the [ __ ] cable like i don't want any
of that [ __ ] it's a brilliant business
model
those guys weigh so much [ __ ] it's
like shenyun i
see it all over the world yeah it's the
one chick yeah yeah
what is it it's a chinese circus ballet
dude it's
everywhere but it's on every billboard
when you see it you cannot unsee it
and they have unlimited dates there's
dates
every [ __ ] day bro how is it
propaganda well that's what i heard
someone
one of my buddies like pro-china stuff
yeah that's right no i think the other
way around
actually i feel like it has to do with a
particular um
maybe ancient or religious beliefs or
like uh practices
that aren't in line with like people's
republics like kind of really
well listen i don't know that i i tried
to look into it but
kind of like body world they're breaking
they're breaking away from the from
china
oh [ __ ] oh wait go ahead go ahead oh no
they just
they just took all the falun gong
chinese dissidents and then they
falun gong if that's what following
that's what shenyan is
okay so yeah that's what this is which
is a a religious movement that's
relatively new
uh starting the 90s and china the
republic of china does not agree
with falun gong so were they based if
china
if they're banned in china are they
basically religions that were founded in
the most recent century
did you know epoch epoch
epic but then someone else is like i
think it's epoch well the actual words
epoch but
they probably pronounce it epic they
just got banned right i don't know
they're banned or not but they're funded
by
falun gong how big is falun gong what is
that what is that
they're the chinese dissidents dude
they're the rebels of china they're
they're like working like
underground they got neo-nazi symbols in
their thing
should we all go together and go watch
it are they like china's queuing on
people or what is that no i think
rebelling against the the state
yeah they don't like the government of
china wow well they they i mean i think
they they believe in like
she entered like all this yeah oh my
dad's into this stuff
oh yeah yeah they're like very into like
i don't know like spirituality and stuff
by the way for the people that don't
know
that symbol existed in asia for
thousands of years before [ __ ] hitler
stole it and made it a racist symbol
i think the nazi one is actually uh
inverted so it goes the other way yeah
but but for people that don't know
they'll think that it's like racist and
nazi and [ __ ]
true but they're heavily persecuted in
china and the and the body world exhibit
is believed to be falun gong members who
were
oh are you serious wow oh that's nuts we
went to go see that
that [ __ ] was wait the body world you're
talking about like the at the left
uh political prisoners that they just
[ __ ] donated these things they're all
asian that's the word that's the word
yeah they're all people of
asian descent you can you can see that
they're
the theory of asian descent when you're
there you can holy [ __ ]
i feel like i miss something so who owns
body world
body world body worlds exhibit falun
gong there's one
i'm feeling like a detective right now
body world falun gong dude
wow i have no idea we are smart on this
channel
yeah start off with a stupid
conversation about drowning in jacuzzis
but just hang in there though but yeah
i'd rather hey people trying to
jacuzzi's all the time
i'd rather talk about combat yeah and
that's our next topic
pretty cool it comes pretty i want to
talk about fault
falling come not falling remember casey
earlier that's a lot of
can we insert that falun gong and uh
body world they got some ties
yeah there's articles about talking
about it but i mean it's like
a quote falun gong practitioners have
been singled out as the most likely
victims meaning
i guess not confirmed but there's
speculation
lots of speculation do they have any
relation to the practice of qigong
i don't know what's that one
like yeah it's like like healing people
with uh it's like a helium
my dad used to take me to this uh chi
doctor in arcadia
all the time when i was a kid that looks
like some qigong [ __ ] right there
that's a picture of someone practicing
falun gong
is manhattan is our hands on a ball like
this right
is it like that yeah she's missing the
the energy ball that the hadoop because
that that's
that's what it is it's like they harness
that but it's kind of a trip
did it work on you no i still can't
breathe out on my nose
it made your nose stuffy yeah well my
daddy used to take me there all the time
and like
i used to hate going there as a kid how
was your septum deviated
yeah i can't oh [ __ ] what happened you
got
i know it was since i was a kid dude or
yeah mostly cocaine
always had a stuffy nose yeah i just
can't breathe out of both of my nose
i always have a stuffy nose too do you
have a deviated septum i don't know
i don't know what it is i self-diagnosed
so you don't know what it feels like to
breathe out of both nostrils
no sometimes i just can't breathe i'm a
mouth breather so
like i don't wanna breathe what's up
dude do you smile i'll bring you guys
nose chips
i i tried i use no strips all the time
and
most of the time they don't really work
you can do they get a surgery right the
way they fix it
i'm on my wife's health insurance now so
i'm gonna get something i bet you guys
save your mind
i bet you i'll kick your [ __ ] ass at
snoring dude
if i lay if i lay straight up i snore it
but if i lay on my side no more snow you
should do a sleep but i drool
bro i could be upside down i'll [ __ ]
snore bro do you wake yourself up
snoring yeah [ __ ] you all the time what
is it what how does nikki do with it
uh thankfully she's a heavy sleeper
otherwise it'd be over a year
damn i want to study more about the
falun gong i heard of them but i forgot
that's fascinating i just thought they
were a cult any rebel group i liked
me too but then like i don't like it
when rebels actually take power
okay so what point do you follow them
and then talk about the american
revolution
when they get too mainstream you're like
nah [ __ ] damn brother because the cycle
of humanity
is the insurgents win they become
well the revolutionaries right they
become the establishment they become the
institution they become the empire
and then they remain that way and now a
new set of rebels need to come
and destroy them there's a great batman
quote about this either die a hero
or live long enough i am batman
wait what well done what is that
well done i don't get it
[Laughter]
i think it was why so serious but if you
understand that cycle right
you feel like the fighting will be
endless yeah
because there's always a new guard like
there's always like
for example like america the great
empire was a revolutionary country right
even like
china like the maoists they were these
revolutionary kids that were against the
uh imperial family and then they took
over
but then like now british empire dude
same [ __ ] it's happening right now
every empire every empire but we have an
empire right now but nobody talks about
it american empire is pretty strong
it's [ __ ] everywhere dude it's all
about the galactic empire yeah
that's what i thought too well according
to the israeli
defense minister there is a galactic
empire which is crazy too
wait the the space force excuse me
though the guy the cat who was in charge
of the israeli space program he rece a
defense minister guy he came out
recently and said that there is a
galactic
federation dude and there's [ __ ]
bunch of aliens in all this country and
you mean all these [ __ ] are like
watching us and like they're playing
chess with us
led by farook in the nation of
domination
[Laughter]
wait is that an american gladiator's
reference because i got it it's from
[ __ ] wwf
and john bradshaw a legion of doom
though those guys were sick
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you